[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous j'aimerais commencer ce
talk en remerciant l'université savoie
mont blanc pour m'avoir donné
l'opportunité aujourd'hui de vous
transmettre une idée j'ai décidé de vous
parler d'une réflexion qui m'est venue
lors de ma première expérience
professionnelle
la vie active est riche et vous ne serez
jamais d'apprendre aujourd'hui je suis
là mais il ya quatre ans j'étais là à
votre place à écouter attentivement et a
joué akonic roche parfois je suis
ingénieur diplômé de l'école polytech
chambéry promotion 2015 et spécialités
bâtiment aujourd'hui je me tiens devant
vous car j'ai décidé de vous parler d'un
sujet très sérieux
le monopoly le monopoly un cadre des
règles du jeu une notice d'utilisation
des objectifs tes joueurs lorsque
j'étais enfant j'ai beau j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps à jouer aux jeux de
société et notamment au monopoly le
monopoly possède une monnaie il vous
faudra savoir calculer utiliser le
calcul mental
si vous voulez compter les billets et
jouer au monopoly ça paraît simple vu
d'ici en tout cas j'espère pour vous
étant l'université mais lorsqu'on est
enfant
et lorsqu'on découvre juste le calcul
c'est compliqué apprendre en s'amusant
quel plaisir pour tout vous dire
c'est avec ce jeu que je perdais le plus
souvent mon calme et aujourd'hui je sais
pourquoi je m'agace et non pas parce que
je perdais mais parce que je n'étais pas
assez formés aux calculs et autant vous
dire qu'avec un père prof de physique
les parties de monopolis transformer
très rapidement des révisions au manque
de maîtrise du calcul créer de la
réticence et je ne prenais aucun plaisir
avec ce jeu le manque de maîtrise mène à
la réticence la réticence men à
l'énervement et l'énervement mène à la
fin de la partie
je me suis fait plaisir
comme je voulais dit un cadre des règles
du jeu une notice d'utilisation la
banque des joueurs laissez moi vous
raconter ma partie de monopoly
elle commence il ya quatre ans le cadre
durant les quatre dernières années j'ai
eu la chance de mener le déploiement
d'un projet à l'échelle nationale et
voici mon retour d'expérience il ya
encore un mois
je travaillais pour audi france
j'entends encore ma mère me dire mais
pourquoi tu vas vendre des voitures
alors tu viens de décrocher un diplôme
d'ingénieur bâtiment c'est pas logique
non j'étais conscient que j'étais
conseiller architectural et chef de
projet pour le groupe audi france mon
travail consistait à accompagner les
partenaires dans la construction de leur
concession automobile et dans la
réalisation de leurs différents projets
aujourd'hui je ne veux pas vous parler
de voiture mais d'un projet en
particulier mon projet ce retour donc
transposable à n'importe quel secteur
d'activité et même à votre vie même à
votre vie étudiante excusez-moi des
règles du jeu la digitalisation
radicalement changé notre manière de
consommer notre rapport à la technologie
a considérablement évolué audi a à coeur
d'être précurseur dans les domaines
technologiques comme vous pouvez le voir
avec le slogan de la marque l'avancé par
la technologie fort prom d'orques
technique
désolé j'ai pas fait allemand élevé de
hambye en 2017
l'allemagne a dévoilé une nouvelle
génération de configurateur pour
véhicules il s'agit d'un configurateur
fonctionnant grâce à un ordinateur
équipé d'une table est contrôlé par une
tablette équipée d'un casque de réalité
virtuelle et permettant de configurer
n'importe quel véhicule de la marque
plutôt que des mots je vous laisse
découvrir ces petites images
arrivée d'un client en concession
présentation de l'audi cote de la
configuration déjà réalisé à domicile
intégration du véhicule dans un
environnement 3d immersifs et
configurations de celui ci comme vous
pouvez le voir
cet outil permet de configurer n'importe
quel véhicule de la gamme des jantes en
passant par la couleur de la carrosserie
de la sellerie absolument tout est chez
audi on peut même configurer son
véhicule sur la lune en vr bien sûr
en 2017 le constructeur a demandé à tous
les pays d'installer ce nouvel outil
dans les concessions mon rôle dans ce
déploiement était d'accompagner les
partenaires en amont et jusqu'à
l'installation de ce projet sur la
partie technique les objectifs un
objectif ambitieux était définie par la
maison mère pour le déploiement de ce
projet à l'échelle nationale
internationale pour la france le réseau
compte 145 concessions et nous avons
trois ans pour l'équipe et ce qui
représente à peu près quatre
installations par mois lorsque ce projet
est arrivé dans la marque
je venais également d'arriver dans la
marque j'ai décidé de en tout cas on va
confier la responsabilité du coup
c'était un vrai challenge pour moi
à ce jour 80% du réseau est équipé et
avec plus de 120 configurateur installé
à l'échelle fin dans le réseau la france
compte parmi les pays au monde les mieux
équipés à l'échelle mondiale par
musculaire ce déploiement étant une
réussite en france
la maison mère a décidé de venir pour
consulter notre notice d'utilisation
j'étais fier que l'interlocutrice de la
maison mère audi aguets s'intéresse au
déploiement en france et j'aurais
présenter le travail dont enfin notre
process dans les moindres détails
entre nous pendant trois ans j'ai
consacré 50 % de mon temps au
déploiement de ce projet j'étais donc
impatient d'avoir leur retour mais
j'étais loin d'imaginer ce qui est
arrivé lorsque mes interlocuteurs
étaient en france nous avons rendu
visite à différents partenaires joueurs
un début de partie
entre nous ça fait plaisir de recevoir
mes interlocuteurs allemands parce que
j'ai travaillé presque deux ans sans
jamais les rencontrer on est d'accord
qu'un petit peu d'humain ça fait plaisir
enfin c'est essentiel même nous étions
donc lors de notre première visite chez
notre chez un partenaire dans la région
parisienne à bord le café autour du
configurateur tout se passait bien et là
le partenaire on nous dit qu'il était
satisfait de son outil mais mais il nous
dit une formation à l'outil aurait été
appréciée car mise à part la mise en
main par l'installateur en anglais il
n'y a pas eu de réelle formation et en
plus en lien avec cet outil
il serait bien de développer une
application qui permet de montrer les
véhicules en stock directement sur
l'écran au client pas bête non seulement
l'application que vous êtes demandé le
partenaire existait déjà mais en plus
elle fonctionnait parfaitement
même sur mon ipad ascenseur émotionnel
je suis passé de ces bons c'est une
visite de courtoisie à ouhlala je
l'avais pas vue venir
et en plus il a fallu que je traduise à
mes interlocuteurs allemands sans mettre
le feu aux poudres
là où d'autres louis just have some
costume d'homme à homme des applications
and putt don't matter case prison
l'information sur le configurateur
n'avait pas été assimilée
mais pourquoi cette question pourquoi
ici et pourquoi maintenant
la maison mère était venue en france
pour avoir un retour d'expérience et je
leur en offrait un en live mais pas
celui que j'aurais pu imaginer
j'ai profité de ce temps kas prison pour
analyser le retour de ce premier joueur
pourquoi demander une application qui
existe déjà
le manque d'information informés
l'information est essentielle à la
réussite d'un projet le personnel de la
concession n'avait pas eu une
information suffisante sur le
configurateur et leur utilisation s'en
ressentent et après un double 6 pour
sortir de case prison et le retour de ce
premier joueur j'ai passé du temps dans
le réseau pour essayer de comprendre si
un joueur des difficultés d'utilisation
avec cet outil
j'imagine qu'il n'est pas le seul nous
avions un outil absolument fantastique
mais son utilisation n'était pas
celle attendue joueurs 2 à vous la suite
lors d'une autre visite j'ai été
confronté à une problématique différente
j'étais en rendez-vous architectural
avec un directeur rappelons le olivier
et à la fin du rendez-vous le directeur
vient me voir et me dit écoute romain il
faudrait qu'on se voie parce
qu'actuellement mon configurateur il est
situé sur la mezzanine et j'aimerais
vraiment le rapatrier dans la zone
clients en rez-de-chaussée
bah écoute olivier pourquoi parce que
moi ton configurateur dans la mezzanine
il est bien placé c'est dans un espace
privatif confidentiel adapté au business
et justement c'est là qu'il doit être
positionné mais oui mais tu comprend
actuellement mes vendeurs on n'utilise
pas du tout le configurateur ils me
disent qu'ils se sentent coupables de
demander aux clients de monter quelques
marches pour utiliser le configurateur
m'écoute olivier moi ce que je te
propose avant de réfléchir un
investissement pour déplacer son
configurateur sais que tu vas te mettre
dans la peau d'un client et tu vas
demander à des vendeurs de te faire une
configuration 7 permettra de voir si oui
ou non le problème vient de la position
du configurateur lorsque tu as fais ça
tu me rappelles
quelques jours plus tard bonjour aux
mains c'est olivier écoute suite à ton
passage sur site et notre discussion
j'ai pu faire le point avec mes équipes
au sujet du configurateur il s'avère que
le problème ne vient pas de
l'emplacement du configurateur mais de
la peur de mes équipes de l'utiliser
je te laisse me rappeler à ce sujet pour
qu'on puisse en discuter merci a bientot
la peur de mes équipes de l'utiliser les
vendeurs avaient été jusqu'à inventer
des excuses loufoque
car ils avaient peur d'utiliser l'outil
et en même temps c'est normal qu'ils
aimeraient se retrouver devant un client
en train d'essayer de vendre une voiture
à plus de 100 milles euros et a pas
savoir utiliser son propre outil de
vente
vous voyez le malaise forme et le manque
de formation amène la réticence de
l'utilisateur final
même exemple communaux poli je ne sais
pas faire je ne fait pas l'effort
non je ne fais pas faire je ne prends
pas de plaisir je ne fait pas l'effort
de l'utiliser
la première utilisation d'un outil est
déterminante son se l'approprient
soit on rejette sans formation c'est
souvent leur rejet qui l'emportent
comme les équipes ne maîtrisait pas
suffisamment l'outil il ne faisait pas
l'effort de l'utiliser et aussi pourquoi
j'utiliserai ce nouvel outil de vente
sachant que je vends des voitures depuis
20 ans avec un stylo et du papier gilmez
accompagner le changement
les gens n'aiment pas le changement et
le changement est dur c'est à ce moment
là que j'ai compris que la que le
facteur humain est cruciale pour la
réussite d'un projet il faut que
l'utilisateur final s'approprient
l'outil
l'outil a beau être performant le
développeur a ball trouver fonctionnel
je trouvais cet outil absolument
fantastique
mais si l'utilisateur final ne le
comprend pas ne l'utilisent pas ne se
l'approprient pas ne le comprend pas il
ne l'utilisera pas à 100% de ses
possibilités
voir il ne l'utilisera pas du tout
mettez vous à la place de l'utilisateur
final
l'année dernière pour noël
j'ai offert à ma mère son premier
smartphone je pensais que c'est une
bonne idée est ce que quelqu'un a déjà
essayé d'aider un proche à l'utilisation
d'un smartphone ça paraît simple pour
vous mais pour eux c'est compliqué il
faut qu'il répète qu'il répète et qu'il
répète pour enregistrer et c'est normal
pour ce déploiement
la partie technique avait été
correctement géré mais une mise en
anglais plus un manque d'information
plus un manque de formation égale une
utilisation partielle du configurateur
imaginez-vous jouent au monopoly sans
avoir lu les règles c'est pas possible
compliqué en tout cas je ne me suis pas
suffisamment positionner à la place de
l'utilisateur final j'ai considérer
l'aspect technique matériel plus que
l'aspect utilisateurs et croyez moi la
meilleure technologie du monde si elle
n'est pas utilisée faire si elle n'est
pas correctement utilisés par
l'utilisateur final ne sera plus la
meilleure technologie du monde à mon
tour de jouer après ces différents
retours
j'ai créé des supports que j'ai mis sur
l'intranet audi je pensais avoir fait le
taf mais ça n'a pas été suffisant c'est
lors d'une dernière visite chez un
partenaire que j'ai tiré une carte
chance et que j'ai compris comment
donner de l'intérêt aux vendeurs pour
cet outil j'étais en avance main réunion
et j'ai profité de cette avance pour
aller voir l'équipe de vente et leur
demander s'ils utilisaient le
configurateur ils m'ont répondu que non
je leur ai donc proposé leur faire une
démonstration
je les ai mis à la place du client et
j'ai pris quelques instants la place du
vendeur pour leur montrer comment en
situation réelle
utilisez l'outil les vendeurs ont été
réellement sensible à cette présentation
car ils ont découvert la puissance de
l'outil on peut parler des faits ou
parce qu'on passe d'un état d'esprit de
ce configurateur j'ai toujours fait son
jeu ça m'intéresse pas à
ah ouais en effet c'est vraiment
intéressant comme outil ya vraiment de
la possibilité au travers de cette conf
de cette présentation
ils ont découvert l'outil ils se sont
appropriés l'outil créer une émotion
positif chez l'utilisateur final
l'émotion permet une meilleure
mémorisation leur intérêt pour cet outil
a été grandement accrue car ils ont
découvert l'expérience qu'ils proposent
ils ont tout à y gagner et ils l'ont
compris
rebattre les cartes fort de ces
différents échanges avec ses différents
joueurs
j'ai compris ce qui m'avait manqué dans
la réalisation de ce déploiement
je n'ai pas suffisamment accompagner le
réseau dans cette transition et ce
changement de technologie un
configurateur actuellement n'est encore
pas capable de vendre des comptes des
phares des voitures tout seul nous avons
donc réfléchi avec avec mon équipe sur
une marche à suivre sur une marche à
sucre qui permettent de demande de
répondre aux demandes des attentes du
réseau j'ai créé un espace documentaire
sur l'intranet avec des guides et des
tutoriels vidéo nous avons commencé à
mettre en place des coaching
personnalisé sur site dans le cadre du
projet audi retail expérience pour
justement aider les vendeurs à utiliser
cet outil est enfin nous avons commencé
à travailler avec le département
formation pour la mise en place d'un
cursus de formation digital il reste
encore du travail mais nous nous sommes
nettement améliorée par rapport au début
du déploiement
je suis fier d'avoir pu prendre le temps
faim je suis fier d'avoir participé à ce
déploiement
j'ai pris le temps d'analyser la
situation comme disait cyril et je me
suis remis en question pour mener pour
essayer de mener ce projet jusqu'à sa
réussite en fin de partie après un
séjour en case prison en cas de diarrhée
trois hôtels acheter il est temps pour
moi de finir la partie
admettez que 18 minutes pour une partie
de monopoly c'est plutôt court je vous
pose maintenant cette question comment
réussir vos projets sans passer par la
case prison
en six lettres l'humain déjà redit de
différentes autres l'humain
mener à bien un projet plus difficile
qu'on ne le pense j'ai appris de ce
projet et c'est pour ça que j'ai
souhaité vous transmettre ses idées
aujourd'hui je vous donne mes clés à
utiliser pour réussir vos projets
attention je parle pas de baguette
magique
ce ne sont pas des formules toutes
faites ce sont des éléments de réflexion
n'attendez pas d'avoir de gros projets
pour mettre en oeuvre ce que je viens de
vous dire vous êtes en tp avec votre
binôme
demandez lui s'il a toutes les
informations avant lui dire je reviens
je me faire les manips vous essayer
d'aider votre grand-mère à utiliser le
bluetooth c'est pas si simple
mettez-vous à sa place l'humain doit
être au coeur de votre projet nous
sommes l'animal le plus sociable sur
terre nos relations avec les autres sont
essentiels classique mais efficace tout
seul tu va plus vite et à plusieurs tu
va plus loin
tu va plus vite et à plusieurs tu va
plus loin vous êtes les personnes qui
demain seraient les acteurs du monde
professionnel
vous avez la possibilité de faire
changer les choses
j'aimerais donc que vous reteniez de ce
talk ces cinq éléments informer former
accompagner le changement se mettre à la
place de l'utilisateur final et créer de
l'émotion positif chez l'utilisateur
final
si vous utilisez ce que je viens de vous
dire et si vous mettez l'humain au
centre dans vos projets dans votre vie
personnelle professionnelle
partout il a de fortes chances pour que
vous évitiez la case prison
il est temps maintenant de finir la
partie
je vous souhaite une excellente réussite
pour votre vie professionnelle avant de
vous laisser je repasse juste par la
case départ pour toucher mes vingt mille
francs
merci et bonne partie à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]